the Donald Trump chief of staff Fiasco
is coming to an end in a sense although
it's also only the beginning in
hilarious fashion you might remember
that Donald Trump previously slammed
Barack Obama for the number of chiefs of
staff that he had Trump is going to
surpass that number in record time but I
want to put that hilarity aside for a
second and focus on the people involved
here chief of staff John Kelly is
heading out he was fired slash quit
slash forced to resign we don't really
know but he's leaving has not been
getting along with Donald Trump he was
headed Trump was in the direction of
selecting Mike Pence's 36 year old chief
of staff to replace John Kelly pence as
chief of staff said not not interested
I'm actually going to leave politics
altogether at the end of the year and
that's why I can't take the job all of a
sudden he has no interest in being in
politics after being invited to be
Trump's chief of staff so then Trump
brings in Chris Christie former New
Jersey Governor met with Chris Christie
late last week chris Christie says yeah
I'm not interested it's not the right
time for my family which I believe I
just don't think there would ever be a
good time for Chris Christie's family
for Christie to be the chief of staff to
President Donald Trump so then Donald
Trump started considering his own
son-in-law Jared Kushner who himself may
not may end up indicted by Robert
Moeller as part of that investigation
but also it would seemingly violate
nepotism laws to hire your own
son-in-law for an official position at
the White House particularly like chief
of staff to the President of the United
States just thinking about hiring Jared
Kushner is bonkers but Trump was not
only thinking about it he was thinking
about it seriously
maybe Jared's not doing quite so well
fixing the israeli-palestinian conflict
and the opioid crisis which was going to
be his other big thing I don't know but
ultimately Trump went away from
selecting Jared Kushner and has instead
settled on Mick Mulvaney the Office of
Management and Budget director who will
start as acting chief of staff in
January when John Kelly leaves
hilariously Donald Trump ended up
settling on the guy who
Trump a terrible human being this is
what Trump could come up with someone
who attacked the core of what Trump is
before being hired by Trump mow veiny by
the way is an outrageous extremist in
his own right he previously said Donald
Trump Trump is a terrible human being we
actually have the video let's take a
look at it the White House asked for
comment on that no comment given so far
Nick Mike Mike Mick Mulvaney is horrible
by the way owes years of unpaid taxes
pat claimed to be against growing the
federal budget until Trump hired him
then blew up the budget to its biggest
ever we covered him I think it was maybe
like six or eight months ago Pat where
he wouldn't meet with lobbyists unless
they had already given money to his
campaign effectively selling access to
himself he's a perfect fit for Trump
were it not for the fact that he called
Trump a terrible human being
and let's not forget Mick Mulvaney was
also the interim head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau and
completely gutted it and so much so that
people working under him decided to
leave because they were not doing a good
job at protecting consumers and going
after lenders and you think that Trump
well any other president any other
person would say that these comments
were made a couple years ago before the
guy worked for me and he did such a
great job as budget director and head of
the CFPB that I'm gonna let it slide
it's water under the bridge but we know
Trump to hold grudges we know that
loyalty is so important to him I don't
know if I don't know if Mick Mulvaney is
the right choice I don't know if he'll
be able to stick around too long yeah I
I just don't think there's any chance
that this is Trump's last chief of staff
this term I just don't see it I think
it's he's not going to last pretty last
longer than scaramouche II I think but I
don't believe that he will be made the
permanent cause he's gonna be acting
chief of staff starting in January I
don't think that this is the permanent
chief of staff for Donald Trump if you
disagree let me know again ideologically
he's so whacked
morally he's so corrupt that he is a
good fit for Trump other than the fact
that we know Trump doesn't tend to like
people who insult him or have insulted
him in the past so we'll see it's
anybody's guess at this point one of the
day's sponsors is privacy dot-com /
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy comm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link